>> Sean: FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
A LONG WHILE, I ACTUALLY AGREE
WITH LIBERAL MITT ROMNEY.
SO, WHAT CAN WE EXPECT FROM THE
WEEKEND SPEECH?
JOINING US WITH MORE, FORMER
ADVISOR TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WHOSE NAME IS MENTIONED QUITE
OFTEN AS A POTENTIAL SENATE
CANDIDATE FROM THE GREAT STATE
OF NORTH CAROLINA, HER HOME
STATE, LARA TRUMP IS WITH US.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, LAURA.
THANKS FOR BEING BACK.
>> YOU GOT IT.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Sean: IT’S SO UNFAIR THAT I
STARTED OUT THAT WAY, ISN’T IT?
BECAUSE I KNOW FOR A FACT, THERE
ARE A LOT OF TOP REPUBLICAN
LEADERS IN NORTH CAROLINA THAT
ARE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT IT,
BUT THEY ARE MAKING A LOT OF
OUTREACH.
IS IT SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD
LEAVE OPEN FOR NOW?
WE ARE NOT ASKING A QUESTION.
LET’S LEAVE THE IDEA OPEN IN
YOUR MIND.
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK, I HAVE TAKEN IT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND I HAVE NO DECISION
TO ANNOUNCE LIVE HERE ON
"SEAN HANNITY" BUT I WILL TELL
YOU TO STAY TUNED BECAUSE IT IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
BE OPEN TO DO.
I AM KEEPING IT OPEN,
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: I WOULD PREDICT YOU
WOULD WIN.
ALL RIGHT, THE PRESIDENT COMING
OUT SPEAKING AT CPAP.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN A MONTH,
FOREIGN POLICY, EXECUTIVE
ORDERS, NO LEGISLATION, AMNESTY
AT THE BORDERS, I MEAN, STRAIGHT
ON DOWN THE LINE A DIRECT
CONTRAST TO EVERYTHING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID.
NOW, I WOULD IMAGINE, I THINK I
KNOW THE PRESIDENT PRETTY WELL,
THAT HE WILL BE HIGHLIGHTING I
TOLD YOU SO.
THIS IS WHAT YOU CAN EXPECT.
THOUGHTS?
>> YEAH, WELL, HE ABSOLUTELY
WILL AND HE DID TELL YOU SO.
A LOT OF US TRIED TO TELL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THIS WOULD
HAPPEN IF JOE BIDEN BECAME
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK THE SPEED AT WHICH SO
MUCH HAS HAPPENED HAS REALLY
KIND OF SHOCKED PEOPLE TO BE
HONEST.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT.
I THINK FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
LONG TIME, AMERICANS FOUND THAT
UNDER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP,
THEY HAD SOMEBODY THEY FELT LIKE
WAS ACTUALLY FIGHTING FOR THEM
AND STANDING UP FOR THEM AND
FIGHTING FOR AMERICA AND
JOE BIDEN HAS MADE IT CLEAR NOT
ONLY THROUGH HIS ACTIONS COME
ABOUT THROUGH WHAT HE HAS SAID,
THAT IT IS NO LONGER AMERICA
FIRST.
HE SAID AMERICA FIRST IS OUT.
WELL, WHO IS A PRESIDENT THAT
DOESN’T PUT THEIR OWN COUNTRY
FIRST?
IT’S ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
BUT THEN YOU SEE THE OPEN BORDER
POLICY.
THEN YOU SEE THE FACT THAT HE
SUPPORTS A BILL TO GIVE AMNESTY
TO 11 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, PEOPLE THAT ARE
ILLEGAL HERE IN OUR COUNTRY,
WANTS TO GIVE THEM CITIZENSHIP.
IT’S REALLY FRIGHTENING TO SEE.
I THINK THE SPEED AT WHICH ALL
OF THIS HAS HAPPENED, WHICH YOU
CAN BET THAT
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IS GOING
TO TALK ABOUT IT.
I’M SURE WE WILL HEAR ABOUT
CHINA.
IRAN.
YOU KNOW, SO MANY THINGS HAVE SO
QUICKLY TURNED AROUND AND REALLY
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY DETRIMENTAL
TO THE FUTURE OF AMERICA.
SO, I’M EXCITED TO HEAR FROM HIM
THIS WEEKEND.
I THINK IT’S GOING TO BE A GREAT
SPEECH.
I KNOW HE’S EXCITED TO SPEAK TO
EVERYBODY THERE AT CPAC.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE ONE ISSUE, WE ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WHEN
THEY TOOK OFFICE, THERE WERE A
MILLION SHOTS GOING INTO
PEOPLE’S ARMS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
A LOT OF THESE DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS SCREWED THAT UP.
AND THEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING, THE POSITION HE IS
TAKING IN THE MIDDLE EAST AND
AROUND THE WORLD, AMERICA LASTS.
BUT THE CALLOUSNESS OF JUST WITH
THE STROKE OF A PEN, GETTING RID
OF HIGH PAYING CAREER JOBS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY MAKING US
DEPENDENT ON FOREIGN ENERGY
SOURCES, TO ME IS THE WORST
THING.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO HAVE ALL OF
THESE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE OUT OF
WORK AND THE PANDEMIC COMPETING
WITH NOW OUT OF WORK ENERGY
SECTOR WORKERS WITH VERY
SPECIFIC SKILLS?
>> YEAH, IT’S SO OUTRAGEOUS.
DAY ONE EXECUTIVE ORDER,
ELIMINATING THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE, PUTTING THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS OUT OF WORK ON DAY ONE
FOR JOE BIDEN.
AND DON’T FORGET, UNDER
DONALD TRUMP FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN HISTORY, WE WERE A NET ENERGY
EXPERT.
WE WERE ENERGY INDEPENDENT AND
WE ACTUALLY EXPORTED ENERGY.
AND ASIDE FROM ALL THE JOBS
BROUGHT TO AMERICA FROM A
NATIONAL SECURITY STANDPOINT, IT
MEANT THAT WE WEREN’T RELIANT ON
THE MIDDLE EAST, ON RUSSIA FOR
ANYTHING.
WE DID IT ALL HERE AT HOME AND
TO SEE THAT JOE BIDEN, AGAIN,
LIKE YOU SAID, WITH THE STROKE
OF A PEN, GOT RID OF ALL THE
GOOD THAT DONALD TRUMP DID,
ESPECIALLY WITH IN THE ENERGY
SECTOR.
THIS IS SOMETHING AGAIN DURING
THE CAMPAIGN THAT YOU HEARD
DONALD TRUMP TALK ABOUT.
JOE WAS NOT GOING TO DO A
GOOD JOB FOR THE ENERGY WORKERS
OF PENNSYLVANIA.
AND HERE, YOU KNOW, DAY ONE HE
GOT RID OF SO MANY.
IT’S ONLY THE BEGINNING.
I THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE
MORE DISAPPOINTMENT FOR PEOPLE
UNDER A BIDEN PRESIDENCY.
>> Sean: MAKE MIDDLE EASTERN
COUNTRIES THAT HATE US AND CHINA